welcome back to this channel in this
video we'll be talking about uh the
basis of pig farming the basis of peak
farming now uh I'm very much aware that
there are several people out there that
are aspiring to start their home Pak
Farm they want to get into Pak farming
and uh some have already started already
and probably they've encountered some
certain challenges or the other and uh
already discouraged well this video is
uh aimed to help uh whoever is in that
situation figure out exactly what they
need to do or if you an aspiring Peak
farmer what you need to prepare for the
kind of mindset you need to have in
order to be successful in Peak farming
now I will start by saying this Pak
farming is very profitable if Done Right
Pak farming is very very profitable if
Done Right is one of the uh is is is a
business that assure you of that if you
do it right you are sure to make your
profit massively very well if you do it
very right but uh the only issue is I
have met several Farmers that are not
doing this right and that's why we are
heing to help everyone out there
aspiring on those that have started to
make Corrections so that we can all have
uh good profits on our pig farm now uh
one of the main issue that has led to um
people getting into Pig farming and
getting discouraged later on is uh the
media Narrative of Pak farming you know
a lot of people watch uh lots of videos
online that talks about uh the success
story around Peak farming but very few
of those videos addresses the challenges
faced in Peak farming so several people
uh in the joy of and in the enthusiasm
of uh getting into business and making
great profits they launch into Peak
farming without uh trying to first of
all understand that Pak farming also has
it challenges but of course with every
every business has it challenges and uh
just like every other business all these
challenges are solvable so and that's
one of the reasons why this video is
help is going is help for everyone to
watch so that you can have the right
mindset uh as you are about to get into
Pak farming and if you are in it already
you can adjust on certain things you
need to adjust on so that we can all
have good profit on our farm now uh if
new to this Channel please uh quickly uh
click the Subscribe button we'll be
bringing to you lot of great videos on
Peak farming for you to understand the A
to Z of peak farming how you are
supposed to have a profitable Peak farm
and all the things you need to know
we'll be bringing them to you we can't
consume everything in one video so we
have to uh break them into sections and
as you have seen in our previous videos
we have been trying to explain certain
things around uh how to treat this how
to treat that some certain challenges
you may face and how you are supposed to
to solve them we have been explaining
some of those challenges and their
Solutions in some previous videos so we
bringing to you lot of videos so please
click the Subscribe button and turn on
the notification Bell so that you can
always get uh notified whenever we
upload new videos all right let's dive
uh straight to what we what we want to
discuss in this video so we want to
discuss the right mindset you need to
have for you to succeed in Peak farming
I'll be talking to you about 10
different mindsets I want every beginner
every uh intending Peak farmer every ASP
uh aspiring Peak farmer to know before
delving or thinking about getting into
big farming 10 different mindsets 10
different mindset I want you to have yes
so number one number one uh is I want
every P aspiring pig farmer to ask
himself a very important question and
the question is are you really ready for
this are you ready for Peak farming uh
do you feel Peak farming is meant for
you because because just like you may
have understood about life generally not
everything is meant for everyone there
are certain things that some people are
meant to do some other people are not
meant to do so you need to ask yourself
are you ready for this that is this
aspect of business is this aspect of
Agriculture meant for you are you able
to handle these challenges is it
something you are passionate about is it
something you will give everything to
you will put in your best or is it
something you just feel like uh
experimenting on so you need to
understand that everything in life and
pig farming is not an exception it all
requires extreme passion you have to be
passionate about what you do you have to
put in 100% 100% into it so it's not
going to be don't feel it's going to be
a cake walk where you just uh leave your
pigs in a pen and uh voila that's it and
uh the money keeps rolling in it's not
like that there are lot of intri cases
that you have to understand about Pig
farming that you have have to uh be
prepared for before you get into it so
that you don't have heart breaks so
please the first question the first
mindset you have to ask yourself while
you're watching lots of videos on how
much money they made from p and
everything is to ask yourself are you
ready for this is it meant for you is it
something you are meant to do so that's
number one mindset number two is what's
your business plan you have to have a
business plan I think I've told you I've
been saying this in some um previous
videos I've been to certain fans and uh
honestly if those were the if those are
the people you look up to you would not
want to get into big fing because uh
they are not in business I can tell you
100% if you do good audit on their Farm
you would discover that these guys are
not in business they just have uh Farm
they just have their Farm they have
animals there but they are not in
business so you have to have a business
plan what's your business plan what do
you him to do now let me just walk you
through some certain mindsets around the
business plan you could have for
instance do you want to be a breeder
that means do you want to have breeders
on your farm do you want to be the
person that brings in uh that um
produces the piglet on your alone or do
you want to be a breeder and be a
partner that means do you want to pick
up the piglet also and also grow them to
maturity you have to have a business
plan you have to have a very solid
business plan what do you aim to do
don't just get there and just take PS
and just start wearing them yourself
what do you into there are different
aspect of this thing for some people now
all they do is buy the piglet they buy
the Piglet and they fix the piglet
somewhere they R them up in about 6
months after 6 months they dispose them
they get new piglets that's a business
plan so these guys those guys that do
such thing they are not interested in
having breeders at all all they
interested in is to have uh a reputable
breeder Farm where they will get their
piglets from every uh every time they
they have in U they AA they available
and they interested in having and put
them in a pen get the feet feed them uh
take them to maturity and dispose them
that's a business plan or okay if you
don't want that plan probably you just
want to be a breeder alone that means
your own job is just to give pigl out to
other Farmers so all you have to do is
to have the Breeders the sa and the bo
uh and uh you call for Farmers
neighboring Farmers to pick piglets from
you every now and then there's a woman I
know that's literally what she's major
majored in uh recently on this Farm we
got Piglet from her from that a farm she
don't keep she hardly keeps any Pig till
6 month or or thereabout but she has
about I don't know how many uh female
pigs she has very great pigs very good
breed and uh she has the she has the T
and she has the Afric the South African
large white and she has a good B she
just has uh the pen she has is not it's
not a very big farm but at least she has
I think probably almost hat um breeder
females so all she do is produce the
piglets people come around pick the
piglets from her and that's great and
she's doing well uh we did the estimate
of how much you'll be making every year
she's making solid money there she's not
wearing anything up to 6 month she uh
after uh having the winners maybe um 5
weeks 6 weeks she disposes all of them
gets the Breeders ready for uh meeting
again and then get them uh bread and
then she makes new piglets again that's
a business plan okay and you can do both
you can decide to have your breeders
maybe you have four females and then you
decide to uh get piglets out of them
after you get piglets out of them you
raise the piglets to 6 months so in that
case now everything has to be well plant
don't go into this without having a
solid plant if not you would you would
just uh find yourself having lots of
Hard breaks because you will be you you
would be one of the people that would
get into P fing and get out a lot of
people call come in and get out in just
like how almost every other agricultural
Venture is lot of people delve in
especially when they watch lot of videos
and later on they get Del out because
they didn't have a plan so they were
they were not able to uh uh to face the
challenges that came with whatever they
were working with now I go with the next
mindset and that have a good budget uh
have a good budget you see your plan
your business plan must be dependent on
the budget you have you know one of the
reasons why you need to have a good
budget is for instance now you need to
know that uh Pig farming is capital
intensive these guys don't uh they don't
hit grasses like that you can't feed
them on grass like that just like the gr
grth growth farming where you could
literally get them to Grace on free
grasses and everything these guys you
have to house them housing them after
you're done housing them you have to
feed them in the morning in the
afternoon so it's a capital intensive
business so you have to be ready you
have to be ready for all these cost you
cannot get the pigs into your farm and
malnourish them and expect to be in
business have a good budget make sure
before you get into um P farming you
know what you are getting into you know
the cost you are getting into how much
will you need to raise a single Piglet
from 1 month to 6 months if you know how
much that is then you understand okay
how much do you have how much are you do
you have how much Capital do you have
available for you do you think you can
raise 10 piglets or do you think you can
raise 20 that should be what should be
your driving force your budget don't get
into this and just probably you just see
animals somewhere and they told you that
uh the animals are quite cheap and you
just feel oh I saw this opportunity let
me get 20 of them and you get 20 of them
and then you can't raise them and then
you are out of business and then you are
struggling and you're having real issues
and the pigs can't eat and they are
catching diseases and they are not
attaining the right kg uh a pig I know
of a farmer that sold his pigs after I
think over 6 months those pigs did not
some of those pigs did not weigh 50 kg
after 6 months after over 6 months pigs
did not weigh uh 50 kg I don't know if
you of course if you're aspiring people
you may not understand how terrible that
is but you see this P you're looking at
in this video on this Farm they are less
than they uh more like let me just say
about 3 months on this Farm they are
weighing some of them will be weighing
if not at least probably 40 kg already
and somebody had uh pigs for over 6
months and could not attain maybe I
think maybe he got 48 kg or thereabout
in some of them or 46 or there about and
he has been keeping these PS for a lot
of time that's exactly what I'm saying I
have a good brother no exactly what
you're getting into because you need to
plan for the right feet you can't plan
for wrong feet you can't plan for just
pkc so that's why I'm telling you please
have a right budget so that you won't
get out of business soon enough number
four start small grow big start small
grow big please you need to know this if
you have uh a lot of money to raise uh
maybe 100 PS I beg you don't go for 100
PS initially if you a new pig farmer
please decide to go for a little number
first no matter how much resources you
have available to you please start small
and Grow Big there is a reason for that
it's not it's not money is not the only
issue in pig farming you need to
understand management management is also
very important you need to understand
there are challenges that may come to
heat to to to your farm your location
may have some certain uh challenges that
you may not be aware of some certain
things that you may not be aware of you
may have issues with your workers you
you may have issues with your water
supply so it may not just be that oh you
didn't have money that was why your farm
had issues it could be some other things
that you have no power over and that's
why I'm saying start small and grow big
if you have the money I would advise you
that no matter how much money you have
make sure you don't start with more than
10 females honestly that's even so much
imagine having 10 females on your farm
if those females give B you could
literally have 100 piglets from just one
bet in like uh 4 months in 4 month time
if you bring in matur females on your
farm you could have you could literally
have 100 piglets in 4 months and that's
a lot of money if you if you consider
breeding those guys still 6 months so
you need to be very much ready for
whatever you are going into but please
start small and grow big number five
focus on your hyals improve structures
later now I understand the importance of
structures in Peak farming I want you to
know that I understand it I understand
the importance of a very solid structure
and I'm not saying you should build a
less solid structure but be very careful
of not going into of designs and all
these things initially of course when
you make great profit on it you can go
on to making a lot of improvement in
your structures you can go on to um
building with using high on and all
those things but if you an intending Pak
farmer and your budget is not very large
of course if you have the money you can
go for good structures and of course it
would not mean anything to you but if
you are having to if you are having to
uh J stose between your animals or your
structures I would advise you every time
anytime every day that you should focus
on your animals focus on their feet
focus on their drugs on their medication
focus on their water supply focus on
those things don't Focus so much on if
you look around this F see some people
use you you could have seen some of our
videos where we made use of bamboo
sticks to do the uh the partitioning see
those animals are doing fine inside of
course that's not the best that's not
the best structure of you if you you
could if you could look at let me try
and show you if you can look at this if
you can look over there you would see
Woods being used to partition the uh the
um pen over there of course if you if
you have money spend the money but I
would advise you if you are if you have
to Jose between what you should spend
your money on your animals or the
structure focus on the animals you can
use l you you need to learn how to
improvise you need to learn how to be
resourceful do lots of things with uh
materials around you don't Focus too
much on I need to make everything solid
with cement the cement bags are very
expensive so if you can do anything with
whatever resources you have around you
please do it and focus on your animal
health focus on them eating properly
focus on them eating the right amount of
protein focus on all those things and
you will never get it wrong in Peak
farming so please focus on your animals
improve structures later if need be
number six as I said already just to
emphasize on it be resourceful try and
on certain things you don't have to
always spend money you don't have to
always spend money it's not every time
you have to look for uh the most modern
way of handling something be uh
resourceful try and improvise try and uh
get uh things around your area try and
look for things that would lessen your
cost the aim for a good business uh uh
activity is for you to have lessened
cost so that your your your profit can
come out from there you don't have to
spend too much on your business so
instead of you running around looking
for the most modern thing right here you
can see we're using the wallo system I
so much love the nipple Drinker I
believe you have seen an improvised uh
way of doing n Drinker that was released
uh some some you should have seen it in
one of our videos on how to uh improvise
the new Drinker using a bucket those are
some of the things I'm talking about you
you need to find a way around all these
things don't be too focused on spending
money uh on just everything you need to
learn how to be resourceful
resourcefulness is the ultimate resource
so number seven market research cannot
be overemphasized your market research
if you are new to PE farming I
understand you may have seen so many
things on the media talking about all
you need to uh understand about uh uh
Peak farming and how much uh it has good
But please understand your location and
understand what your location
needs you need to make sure that your
location is in demand for this thing
don't be too carried away with what you
see on the internet market research
cannot be overemphasized before you get
into into Peak farming go around your
area and find out what's the demand for
paks in your area and what size are they
are they in demand for what do people
need what do people require
are people searching for the piglet so
before you think about going into
breeders Farm ask yourself is are people
is the demand for piglet in your area is
it very solid you have lots of farmers
looking for piglet before you decide to
be a breeder farmers and ask yourself
also if you want to R till 6 month like
what's the number what's the number of
pigs that you think you will be able to
dispose in a month so that you don't
have 100 Pigs and the demand is 50 so
you I understand that in some places the
has not been met But be sure that that's
the case in your area ask yourself where
are you locating your farm and how long
how what will you what will it take for
you to transport your animals from your
farm to wherever the market is you know
obviously markets will be somewhere
somewhere but do you have the right
resources to transport your animals from
where you are if there there are no
markets in your area to where Market is
these are important things you need to
pay attention
to so number eight invest in knowledge
invest in knowledge train your workers
you see it is uh deception real
deception if somebody tells you all you
need to do is just to get pigs and put
them in a place and not all that's real
deception I'm telling you it doesn't
work that way you need to have somebody
somebody somebody somewhere that is an
expert somebody that you can always
reach out to somebody that you can
always call upon you could go get to
your farm one morning and you will see
your pigs acting out you can see you
could decide you could discover some
certain things that you've never
experienced before you need to have the
right knowledge invest in knowledge and
that's why we we bring to you several
content on this farm and I've told you
already we're not going to hide anything
everything you need to know about P
farming that we're going to Dish
everything out on this channel and if
you're new here please make sure you
subscribe click on the subscription
button and make sure you turn on the
Bell notification so that what whatever
we bring great content you can always be
notified so invest in knowledge invest
in knowledge the right vings the right
uh uh drugs the right biomedical uh
security measures that you need to have
the right how do you build your
structures what are what what's the
requirement for uh structures on in Peak
farming what's the spacing how many PS
should you put in a in some certain uh
space do you just fixing you see some
fers fixing like almost 20 PS in a
certain space what's the requirement
invest in knowledge so that you don't
make mistakes and make sure you invest
in knowledge before you get into it so
that you don't get into an error before
you got into uh before you just while
you're starting and then it St you a lot
to correct the error so please invest in
the right knowledge train your workers
if you have workers make sure you train
them train them how to inject your paks
you don't have to be on the farm all the
time your worker should be able to take
the initiative to inject the animals
know how to give them the highve metin
know how to identify when they having
diarrhea and how to treat uh the
diarrhea know how to dearm your paks
invest in knowledge train your workers
very well train your workers what are
the signs they need to look look out for
to be sure that your pigs are not sick I
think we have addressed that on in this
channel already train your workers very
well so that you can have the right
profits on your Farm Number Nine be
ready for challenges be ready for
challenges I want you to know that it
doesn't matter how much you put if you
call on the best expert to if you the
best consultant consulted for you for
you to start your Pak Farm if you I
don't know if you read the best books on
Peak farming if you have uh you made the
best research on Peak farming on the
internet I don't care whatever you do
you're going to face challenges on your
P Farm it is bound to happen so be ready
for challenges and you have to be
Resolute stay Resolute you don't have to
give up in this in the face of
challenges the fact that you're
experiencing something in your farm
doesn't mean you have to fold up your
farm doesn't mean you have to pack up
your farm invest in knowledge but also
be ready for challenges it's not because
you're doing something wrong all the
time it may just be just the
circumstance of life that would always
happen life has challenges you have to
learn how to solve them don't uh give up
stay Resolute don't don't let ever let
whatever happens turn you uh uh make you
discourage and you get out of pig
farming stay Resolute I want you know
that the xra in everything was once a
beginner so whatever you are facing as a
solution you just have to make uh your
right research sometimes and uh
sometimes you have to experience some
things for you to know better and to
know how to solve those challenges
better and then number 10 which is the
last but not the least prey that's the
last thing prey I haded that there
because you need to understand that the
best of the best uh the best of the best
Farmers the most uh the best Farms out
there they face challenges that they
cannot solve I don't know if you have
seen situations where you will see on
cattles all dead I've seen it before you
see people uh maybe uh a Veterinary came
to the to inject the animals and killed
several of their goats I that happened
recently in a certain Farm several of
their goats di those are not things that
came because the guys were not expact or
because they did not put everything
right it's just some of the things you
just need to pray about and uh and trust
God to help you because this is life and
so you need to know that there are
certain things that are out of your own
hands the best of the best Farms out
there they face challenges that they
cannot solve so the last but not the
least mindset is
all right I think this uh should have
been very helpful for every P aspiring
Pak farmer out there if you are new to
Pak farming or you just thinking about
starting your Pak Farm you need to know
all these things put all this in place
you can always reach out to us if you
need help on everything on anything so
that we can help you we can guide you
we're ready to help you we want you to
be profitable in your Peak farming
project I've seen lots of farmers that
are doing very badly very poorly some of
them are around me very very poorly when
it comes to um Pig farming and I don't
want that to uh continue so this is for
everyone out there that that is getting
into Pig farming you a beginner in in
pig farming please know the right things
to do and make sure you're ready for
whatever comes at you so I wish you all
the best again once if you're new to
this channel make sure you subscribe cck
the subscription button we'll bringing
lots of videos lot of great videos
you'll be meeting them on this channel
we'll be at least in a week you should
not get less than three to five content
we'll bringing lots of videos on this
channel thank you very much bye-bye oh